hi everyone I'm jeev nah hectare and I'm
Jolin Tio and we're both customer
engineers at Google cloud and we are
excited to share with you the launch of
the grow series the third and final
season of the Google Cloud technical
guides for startups a series of videos
for technical enablement to help
startups to start build and grow your
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud our mission begins with
you and we're invested in helping you
build your business with Innovative
technology and holistic support from
Google Cloud hence whether you're in
your early stage of your product Market
fit or you've just received your next
round of funding we're here to help you
grow
with the successful completion of season
1 the start series which focused on
helping beginners and early stage
startups in their pre-trial phase to
manage and deploy new applications on
Google cloud and the successful
completion of season 2 The build Series
where we helped customers to build on
Google cloud and optimize the
deployments we're delighted to be
launching season 3 The Grow Series this
series is designed to help startups to
grow and scale their deployments in the
grow series not only will we be covering
some exciting and innovative solutions
but we will also be highlighting some
industry specific use cases
in this bro series we will be together
navigating through a whole trail of
exciting topics on Google Cloud we
kicked off the series with this launch
video to give you an overview of what to
expect from The Grow series which Builds
on top of the start and build series we
have the entire multi-play list Linked
In the description box below so we
suggest you navigate to that if you're
new and are just getting started on
Google's cloud
in our second video we'll be sharing
with you how you can uncover insights
with Luca and explore real-time business
analytics easily
following that we'll then explore how
you can start at zero and optimize your
startup for sustainability
after which we'll also be diving into
how you can scale your startup with
Cloud spanner as well as alloy DB which
combines the best of Google with one of
the most popular database engines for
performance scale and availability
from there we'll start looking into some
industry use cases beginning with how
you can architect the trending error of
blockchain on Google Cloud
following that we'll then Deep dive into
how startups can innovate with Google
Cloud's machine learning Solutions
and also how you can accelerate model
development with machine learning
operations or ml Ops 2. we'll then move
on to another territory as to how you
can architect a retail startup on Google
cloud and then dive into the topic on
how to modernize with anthos for your
startup's hybrid connectivity networking
needs and finally we'll be looking into
our final industry deep dive on
architecting a healthcare startup and
last but not least wrap up our entire
multi-series
and with that that's a wrap on the grow
series as well as our multi-series of
start Build and Grow if you are new to
the Google Cloud technical guide for
startups do check out our introduction
videos for both season 1 and season 2.
start and build respectively to find out
more and begin your journey with us
we are thrilled to be walking alongside
you on your startup journey across
different stages of start Build and Grow
to explore Concepts at each stage
step-by-step guides and deep dive into
industry specific use cases too
to add on not only do we have a YouTube
playlist We also do have a startup
website full of resources such as
handbooks startup reference
architectures blogs and more be sure to
check it out
so for our very next stop in our next
video we will look at how you can
uncover insights with Lookout this
includes an overview of the lookup
product family and when to choose which
solution introduction to Luca and deep
tag with the demo and a customer success
story
please like and share this video And
subscribe to this YouTube channel if you
haven't already we hope that you are as
excited as we are to be on board this
journey together we're so happy to see
how far you've come just a little more
to go so hi and we will see you very
soon on the other side
[Music]